yeah welcome to this video would see for
what okay let's play something else okay
Evan now you can play the final alright
the kind of a grand prix simula at least
ok let's take down and now he's playing
that curious ok but i can take de de
shouldn't be too bad
hmm 96 he can maybe take at some point
and then I have some serious problems
with them with them keeping e5
hmm yeah White is certainly okay here
this was I could have played 96 actually
all right it's not not a big issue my
ideas to play efore and 95
oh yeah and to know
if I play Queen f7 to h5 is this too
ambitious maybe still let's let's try
that one too well I don't want to get
too too passive in this position against
the two bishops try to get something
going on the king
ah this is interesting I go night-night
g-form
wait if i go on IG for what is he doing
III the key fix if is covering that can
I take on edge to play Knight g4 Queen
h5 with Queen urge to mate hmm
hmm not sure I can also just take f
three hits not bad and I but let's do
let's do that and see what is coming up
with now this was to be expected I take
it wind energy for and queen here I can
imply Quinn and I def three threatening
made himself if I play III intending
night with two which is completely
ridiculous okay at some if I don't do
that this didn't make any sense at all
I'm also having 94 now 94 to somewhere
yeah it's maybe not the most correct way
to play but it seems interesting so i
can go 94 now i want to
tango Queen to h5 of maybe if he goes h3
now I have a night f2 what I don't have
is naughty for now because of the mate
on g7 okay preventing age 3 is not not
look bad I can do that him a treat still
not have to I hope I didn't overlook
something wow isn't this i 95 at the end
hoops night g5 wait wait wait wait wait
night h3 Bishop Queen 95 what a sick
move and then e6 was hanging at the end
okay i also have 94 in this position
here night before but he's got at least
Queenie one
yeah I need to do that what what else
yeah I need some activity night Bishop
to g5 this was my idea with p5 c6 was
hanging maybe you could have taken it
very likely actually I take it now I
cannot calculate this
again this age 3 thing maybe yes some
technical win 97 or something 97 king of
eight took a three for example to work
check
mmm yeah maybe check
I'm not seeing a direct window it's a
discovered check but no checkmate I hope
hmm maybe this is working would be pure
luck but sometimes you need some of that
check
it's rookie too I want to play
and rookie 3 is even stronger okay
three-time warning check
check check check
checkmate yeah sometimes you're just
lucky yeah we really all play me I think
it was completely busted here 96 96 wins
everything winds probably i can just
briefly but what I relied upon was that
here I can take on on a three but it's
not working because of this one and I'm
just losing this piece and this means
that the whole concept was was wrong me
to go here and now I'm upon down and
it's also just a crap position 95 coming
it's basically over just trying to muddy
the waters yeah this gives up some of
whites edge but it's still winning I
guess 97 half course again he can just
take it you can just take on on rook
here playing this wins yeah of course I
mean I was busted time I was sure that
there is something this is already a
draw funny enough and this loses like an
even exchange and through crook check
yeah didn't see that but this is also
winning yeah can check check yeah this
was winning the queen or meeting yeah
just a just a very lucky winner thanks
for watching